so so that's part of why that's another  part of why i'm opposed to the public  reason position which says that we all  have all have to appeal to this body of  principles which is nothing more than  what's inherent in liberal democracy  i think that that  if we ever actually did it  results in a  flattening  a making shallow of public discourse  i think when i invite my fellow jewish  people to say how they think about  politics from a jewish perspective i  learned something  something of depth  i think it's a matter of my respecting  them  if i go up to them and say but you're  not using raw's in public reason i think  that's insulting them but only apart  from that there's there's a death that  is brought to politics by reflective  religious people  speaking speaking up and death and  that's what tony was talking about if  we've only got the andrans and the  economizers and the nationalists around  imagine  imagine that  it's just  flat and shallow